pas de surprise en bulgarie les
résultats provisoires donnent le parti
de l'actuel premier ministre boiko
borisov en tête des votes face à la
situation sanitaire beaucoup craignaient
un taux de participation très faible
mais les bulgares étaient au rendez vous
hier selon la commission électorale
avec près de 40% de participation en fin
d'après midi contre 42% en 2017
boyko borisov a réagi sur les réseaux
sociaux en quête de stabilité politique
il appelle ses opposants à le rejoindre
pour venir à bout de la troisième vague
de kobe 19 qui traverse le pays
je vous offre la paix nommons les
experts et d'ici décembre
nous pourrons sortir de la pandémie et
aller de l'avant
c'est l'offre que je vous fais à tous
choisis sont les meilleures personnes
pour faire le travail
l'union fait la force je sais de quoi je
parle et je suis heureux que tant de
partis soit entré au parlement car je
suis fatiguée de porter seul toute la
responsabilité
une coalition inévitable pour gouverner
avec seulement près de 25% des voix le
parti conservateur gerb est au pouvoir
depuis 2009 sera loin d'obtenir la
majorité absolue au parlement face à un
paysage politique morcelé
la tâche pourrait s'avérer compliquée
pour borisov
les différents partis ont pour la
plupart déjà rejeté toute coopération
avec le géant herbes et les résultats
officiels définitifs ne seront pas
connus avant ce jeudi